this is adam mason reading in for
reviewer richard wakeling what happens
when you take a bunch of teenagers
strand them alone in the middle of the
woods and leave them with naught but a
foreboding warning that's just begging
to be ignored nothing good is the answer
but that's exactly why we're here this
is the devilishly appealing setup for
the quarry supermassive games spiritual
successor to until dawn after dabbling
in shorter stories with the dark
pictures anthology series the quarry
sees the studio return to its roots with
a new 10-hour horror game that sticks
closely to the well-received formula
that made until dawn such a rousing
success
help him
after a mysterious and unsettling
prologue the quarry's first act begins
on the last day of summer camp with all
the kids sent home only the councillors
and the camp's owner remain he's anxious
for everyone to leave as quickly as
possible which immediately throws up a
few red flags but when their minivan
fails to start the council is forced to
spend another night together being
teenagers they come up with the grand
idea to throw one last party before
heading home in the morning no harm no
foul right obviously things don't quite
go to plan and not just because booze is
hard to come by so you'll spend the
evening switching between control of all
nine councillors as they attempt to
survive the night against numerous
unforeseen threats
[Applause]
and delving into any more detail would
really infringe on spoiler territory and
part of the quarry's charm comes from
uncovering its enticing mysteries there
are some fairly obvious hints early on
that should give you a good idea of what
you'll be up against but things aren't
always as they seem and the revelations
keep unfolding right up until its final
moments one thing that is for certain is
supermassive's reverence for horror
movies the quarry wears its influences
on its sleeve with various elements of
its design evoking some of the genres
very best the summer camp setting is
clearly inspired by the likes of friday
the 13th and the cult classic sleepway
camp though the less said about the
latter the better its self-awareness is
reminiscent of the scream franchise and
there are also allusions to the likes of
the texas train tour massacre and the
hills have eyes among others even the
casting reflects this affection with
supporting roles for several
recognizable horror mainstays such as
david arquette lynn shay lance henriksen
and ted raymie does this look like the
goddamn harbinger motel to you
by exuding this unmistakable passion
there's an air of confidence around the
quarry that reassures you that you're in
the right hands for a quintessential
teen horror experience and this is most
definitely the case its cinematography
is often stunning effectively capturing
fog creeping through a forest on the
reflection of the moon on the lake's
surface it constantly toys with the
contrast between light and dark too
allowing for surprises to emerge from
the shadows when you least expect it the
camera work is also much improved
creating suspense through oppressive
close-ups and moments where the camera
will hang back framing its characters as
though an unseen stalker is behind the
lens
the cast of playable counsellors runs
the gamut of familiar genre archetypes
there's jacob the boisterous jock dylan
the wisecracking oddball and abigail the
socially awkward artist just to name a
few they can sometimes encroach on
caricature territory but much like until
dawn the quarry manages to subvert
expectations once it digs beyond the
surface level the ensemble cast is also
excellent with plenty of strong
performances bringing each counselor to
life the impressive technology plays a
significant role in this presenting some
of the most realistic looking animated
faces in gaming the fear in a
character's eyes is palpable and you'll
also notice when they're being
flirtatious through subtle changes in
expression it allows the actors to
convey different emotions without having
to say a word when it is talkative
dialogue is snappy and feels very
natural in that quick witted normal
people don't actually talk like this
hollywood style of conversing which is
befitting of such a cinematic game hey
give me your number i want to try it out
why
uh so that i can ask you out on a date
uh um smooth
it's genuinely funny too making sure to
fit in moments of levity even in the
direst of circumstances and never
threatening to take itself too seriously
it also dedicates plenty of time to
developing the bonds between each of its
characters and letting you get to know
them the first two hours or so are very
light on scares as you're given a chance
to see how these characters act around
each other before the [ __ ] hits the fan
not everyone will appreciate this slow
approach and it does run into a few
other pacing issues later on with scenes
dragging their feet to the point where
it feels like some of the fat could have
been trimmed but in a game where anyone
can die it's imperative that you care
about what happens to those living on a
knife's edge of course if you're not
vibing with a character you can always
take pleasure in ensuring their eventual
demise
the quarry is built on choice and
consequences all throughout the game
you're forced to make decisions that
will shape what happens to each
character whether you're picking between
two dialogue options choosing which path
to take or ruminating on pulling a
shotgun's trigger play your cards right
and you could see everyone survive the
night or fail so catastrophically that
no one is left alive come sunrise
sometimes these choices might seem
inconsequential until a few hours down
the line while at other times they can
directly seal a character's fate go
right here why come on scenic route one
last victory lap around the camp
sure what's the victory
two months no technology
quick time events punctuate moments of
action to keep you involved but they
feel more like additional choices than a
test of your reflexes you simply need to
flick the left analog stick to the right
direction to succeed with the face
buttons reserved with the occasional
button mashing and moments where you
need to hold your breath some of the
tension is subdued when compared to
until dawn since it's unlikely you'll
ever fail one of those qtes but it does
place a bigger onus on your decisions as
opposed to your reactions death is also
not final in the quarry if a character
dies you have the option to spend one of
three lives to rewind time and hopefully
alter their fate by imposing a limit on
how many times you can do this it
doesn't eliminate the threat of death
you just have another decision to make
do you spend a life now to potentially
save this character or pocket it for
later in case someone you like more meet
a bloody end the only downside to this
mechanic is that sometimes the fatal
choice might have occurred 20 minutes
ago which means having to replay a
lengthy chunk of the game again when
you're not making spur moment decisions
and avoiding death via qtes you're given
the chance to explore some wonderfully
realized locations as you unearth more
of the game's secrets through numerous
collectibles
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
i'll tell chris about it when we see him
the quarry occasionally adopts the fixed
camera angles that were prevalent in
until dawn during these moments but for
the most part you're given full camera
control as it nestles above a
character's shoulder this makes
searching for various clues and evidence
a tad easier but the camera still sits
in tight which when combined with the
cinematic letterboxing creates an
inherent sense of claustrophobia
exploring each area also gives you the
opportunity to unveil different turret
cards that offer a brief glimpse into
the future this has been a feature in
supermassive's other games but they're
still too vague and obfuscated to feel
particularly useful or enlightening
you're also locked into a slow walking
speed during these segments so veering
off the beaten path only to find nothing
can be frustrating if you do want to go
back and see how things could have
played out differently there's a movie
mode that lets you sit back and watch
events unfold you can opt to watch a
play through where everyone either lives
or dies or use the director mode to
predetermine the behavior of all nine
counsellors and see what kind of effect
that has on each scene supermassive
doesn't shy away from the fact that the
quarry is essentially an interactive
movie the mechanics haven't evolved
since until dawn was released seven
years ago and that's perfectly fine the
basic system of choice and consequence
is still highly effective at building
suspense and lending a massive amount of
weight to each decision you make its
characters are personable well written
and superbly performed ensuring that you
care about what happens to them and the
story takes plenty of exciting twists
and turns that make you eager to find
out what's going to happen next you may
only make a contribution every few
minutes but that doesn't stop the quarry
from being a fantastic horror game and
super massive's best venture to date
okay
i got this
[Applause]
that shotgun's got a hell of a spread be
careful
okay okay all right